we've also got a bunch of other games to
talk about here and another one they
showed up they started the show off with
actually was doom and I was left a bit
cold with this one what did you think
Lucy um I was excited because they said
it was it tech six mmm or six six sixes
they call it and I was like it's always
spend the whole thing I looking at it
and then I was like it lists it looks
pretty I'm look that pretty if it was ok
what did you think about the the
locomotion in a Kevin was it supposed to
be fast the doom has always been it felt
feels way more fast than that to me yeah
like I don't know like it just fault
thing I think I think 40 demo though hmm
I mean obviously when you play Doom it
is incredibly fast paced and whatever
but I think for a demo you can't put
that on screen because if you're showing
off your engine as well especially for
the first time properly you want to be
able to see say to people look at all
this crap we built like look at it look
at good it looks well whatever you don't
appreciate this when you play it you
look at now every time he lifted up a
gun I was like oh look at the guns are
you getting hard looking at the gun now
it's like Sophie's of like everything
off a dead body and the guy was you know
like there was forced by I like that so
this was the demo they showed afterwards
but the original part of this that they
showed off was on a straight up like old
Mars base like this is definitely base
within the same world that they're going
for with with with doom 3 in terms of
the UAC holding a base and then and the
hell hellscape opening up we get some
footage of that ought to be great and
that whole section that they showed off
introduced a bunch of the weapons are on
offer they showed the shotgun the super
shotgun and they also showed off a lot
of these contextual deaths that they
yeah a lot of environmental stuff as
well like really big explosions by
shooting things in the environment which
is cool I was it just me ur that you
guys think that they were repeating a
lot of those debt sequences over and
over again I saw quite a few of the one
where they rip off the leg and him in
the head with it I thought there was a
lot of a repetitiveness I think in the
gameplay the one where it was just like
the leg left standing in the half body
yeah yeah it's like running yeah it was
just a bit it's it's weird because he
was plowing through so many of these
characters like it was it was all
was felt like something like Bulletstorm
were you just soaking these dudes up and
for me like I know that when you go back
and think about do one and two now
they're not the scariest games in the
world but those games have an element of
like this is hard like it's me up
against hordes and hordes of enemies and
if you're setting it right you're in a
difficulty that actually feels like it's
it's it's challenging obviously they
can't you know show that off at a
conference and have you dying over and
over again but there's something about
this it just seemed like it felt like
more like serious sam as soon as Sam was
on the ridiculous end of that how much
yeah I get that I get that a lot I'm
just bored by a lot of this honestly and
I feel bad because I know that some of
my Twitter feed was like oh it's
exciting and look at all the gore and
then some more of the look at the gore
and also did you notice the blood and
yeah and I'm just like this is this is
first person shooter the first person
like this is the first person shooter
the first person shooter the first
person she like it's just is what it is
and I just kind of expected more I guess
it doesn't mean that I don't think a
game can just be it's okay for a game to
just be fun but I'm just looking at it
thinking but what is it that this is
bringing me that I can't already get in
pain killer and a bunch of other games
it's yeah you'll very much like this it
felt to me like the type of game has
been passed through a bunch of different
like public like testing and just round
it off because not only like they're
returning all these games like that bear
bf3 one that is whatever is back there
like they're showing off the plasma gone
they're showing off all of these guns
and they all looks like the same great
thing it was basically shooting
projectiles there was no like feeling of
oh this is like different like there was
in so many right Ames like quake 2 is
like the best grenades in video game
ever like the railgun you think like to
me or this felt more like a quick I even
said quake there this felt more like a
quake in terms of your ability to just
mow down tons and tons of enemies yeah
I'm to me just didn't feel like a do
middle and I was thinking of unreal when
during moments like this where he's just
switching between the different the
different types of weapons and thinking
oh that that's not like a little bit
like unreal tournament yeah so
regardless of our impressions of the
gameplay they showed off some other
stuff at snap map which is their new
technology for yes for sending dick pics
around the world and doom no percent for
making a levels which in and of itself
is a little bit worrying if they're
making modular level design for
again the you know in advance yeah I
think that's cool in that they're trying
to introduce her to a new audience like
console especially if the tool kit works
and if it's intuitive enough and people
obviously jump on it um it's an up next
they showed off some multiplayer things
as well they had a 4 on 4 and 4 m mode
in there they had or wave base mode in
there as about the time I was starting
to fall asleep he mentioned cooperative
mode cause of the way babe this one and
they said 2016 as well and yeah part of
so it's coming out next year maybe we'll
see more office maybe being a little bit
rough on and I don't know it just i came
in at ibis probably do bad thinking that
wasn't too hard also this is part of
bethesda nesh which is their new yeah WB
play anymore bows exactly their new
origin any problems which is an online
environment in which all of these games
will be launched a bull and whatnot i
don't know i was glad they finished
before I've because for me add the doom
enhancement wasn't wasn't too hot final
thoughts on doom Alexa I don't think
I've seen enough to really be like whoo
yet I mean it looks fun but beyond that
I yeah it's their name alright I guess
we'll have to wait and see oh that's not
what you think of doom in the comments
are we being a little bit too tough on
it were you disappointed as well or did
you think it looks pretty badass let us
know down below
you